what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
Pearl daily where I cover this week's
treachery debauchery and craziness
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and bring that
notification Bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos like
the video on your way in and while
you're at it guys get yourself a women
shouldn't vote t-shirt today if you want
to be the ultimate alpha male and have
women come up to you left and right get
yourself a women shouldn't vote t-shirt
um shipping should go out in the next
two weeks guys I appreciate your
patience on the t-shirts it's our first
time doing merch I promise they are
coming um but yes get yourself a women
should have vote t-shirt okay so um
today we're going to go over a couple of
topics and the first topic I wanted to
talk about was Britney Runner so as you
guys know um Britney Runner came on the
show about six months ago and Britney
Runner is a woman that is famous for I
I'm sleeping around right and she had a
whole you know this is isn't even me
talking bad on her she had a whole book
talking about her sexual escapades and
she's been in the media for like I don't
know 10 10 years maybe and she came on
to my show a couple of months ago and
she talked about how she had deep regret
for some of the things she had done I
hate how I allowed myself to just be
like used up by men and that came from a
lack of selfworth I did not understand
my value that I was born with I didn't
and I
gave again people look at sex
differently but sex is spiritual
unification at the end of I don't care
how you spin it it's for women okay
let's okay whatever okay fine for women
it's spiritual
unification and people that I shared my
body
with when I think about my list it's
repulsive because they didn't deserve it
but that was an outcome of me
discounting my worth MH and it's
disgusting
um I hate even having that spiritual tie
in any type of way but yeah I I would
absolutely change sexually how I move
around now a lot of you guys say that I
have no empathy and pearl is just a big
meanie but but I will say women like
Britney rener have been failed um
they've been given terrible advice from
two generations of women and the media
markets to them a terrible message and
they're rewarded for it now does that
take accountability off of her and say
that she shouldn't F the consequences of
her own actions no uh but I will say
when Britney came she genuinely I would
say was a nice person she was super nice
to me she was super nice to my staff and
I honestly have nothing really bad to
say about her um which is why I think
it's actually unfortunate that she keeps
going viral for the wrong reasons she
was on Shannon Sharps and I I don't I
don't even know who that is like a
footballer or something um his podcast
so he brought on Britney let's bring it
up I've had sex with 35
guys
[Music]
okay woo oh
Lord impressive isn't the word so if I'm
judged for anybody else need a shot of
this if I'm judge for having great taste
we are in the bar so help yourself
we got this for the next
hour you know on one hand I I will give
it to her you know I mean she's everyone
says she's lying it's higher you know at
least at least she's being somewhat
honest but but the thing is we're we're
in a society where this type of behavior
is rewarded you know she she goes viral
she she makes a whole career out of this
and so I'm not really surprised when we
keep seeing another 22-year-old version
of Britney rener there's just going to
be the next like round of girls that
really does this and it's unfortunate
because just being someone that has
actually met her in person you know she
was actually perfectly nice to me I know
she has other qualities like outside of
sex it's unfortunate that that's like
what we what she goes viral for and
that's what she's like putting out there
um you know cuz it's one thing to have
done something and regretted it but it
you know when you're you're going on
podcasts and you're bragging about it
it's just not a good look you know um
and it's unfortunate CU I was really
hoping like she would have like a
Redemption era but you know and this is
why guys will say you can't really make
a wife out of a hoe because they always
go back to the streets they'll start
bragging about their sexual escapades
and really it's not like actually regret
for most of them you know and this is
why I say guys you know over a certain
age I would just be done I just say
women in general kind of done over a
certain age and I think there is
something we can learn from from the way
that women react to Red Pill content
women have gotten to the age of 30 35 28
22 and have never ever heard what men
want how crazy is that and so when men
say we don't like fat chicks we actually
need you to bring something to the table
no this is not good enough women freak
out they get mad and it's really
interesting I can tell a lot about a
chick by how she reacts to the red pill
okay so and what is the red pill the red
pill is just the truth about the world
what is true you know when I say
marriage is a bad deal for men
today women that tend to make better
lives are a bit more agreeable and
inquisitive they want to know
why where on the other hand you get
women that shame men for their opinions
they shame me and other podcasts for
really just showing the reality of the
world today you know I I didn't make
this world I I just was born into this
mess you know um and so this woman
claims that she lost her boyfriend to
Red Pill content let's pull it up so my
boyfriend turned red pill and at this
point we haven't spoke for about a month
and I can't cope with the fact
that
someone who I saw is so
compassionate and thought and
intelligent so caring and
open-minded just completely did a 180
they were just so supportive and caring
and even when I would have my self-
sabotaging episodes they still loved me
I feel like red pill men stole my future
husband from me because I really really
thought this was the person and even
after talking about this I'm like phys
physically shaking because it was just
so bad like at this point in my life I
don't I don't want anybody I don't want
to be with anybody if they're going to
do that to me if they could just treat
me that
way I don't want anybody I don't want to
be with anybody good to me they could
just treat me that
way all right I want to it's like I
don't want to be with anyone she wants
all this sympathy okay then die alone
just like the men do oh my gosh okay God
I just can't deal with the simpery I
just can't I it just it is just driving
me crazy the level of simp all right you
know and she's young but young women are
supposed to have the men around them say
hey this is
unacceptable and older women all
right I wanted to point out cuz I was
listening very closely to the words that
were coming out of her mouth she
admitted that she has poor emotional
control and she didn't want to be
controlled and she also admitted that
she had quote unquote self- sabotaging
episodes okay so maybe there was
something that you needed to do to
improve maybe it wasn't the red pill
content maybe it was just you weren't a
good
girlfriend and that's okay you know it I
am just here's here's one thing that I
do how do women react when you tell them
they're not the hottest things and
sliced bread we have been told since we
are so young that we are so amazing and
so special and so awesome and that you
know you deserve to be loved and this is
this Gosh guys I just can't with the
women's like shame insult guilt need to
be right I see this on Twitter they're
like Pearl you you deserve to be loved
by somebody and I and I thought about
this and I and I sat and I sat I thought
about
this and I remembered I'm like you
realize nobody deserves
anything at all and the thing is men
know this when men get dumped it's so
interesting to see the difference
between when men get dumped and when
women get dumped okay when men get
dumped they say where did I go men are
so funny men are this is how a lot of
them find the red pill men are so funny
they will like obsess over like what
what could I have done and I think
that's why men are so confused about
like attraction because they're like hey
this is what women said they find
attractive they said if I buy the
flowers the Roses if I do everything she
says then I'll be attract I mean that's
why the W that's why the men are like
confused because Men actually get
feedback and adapt and listen right so
they'll you'll say hey the women will be
like look
we want some jacked guys uh that make a
lot of money and the men will be like
all right let's work to do that so when
they get dumped they kind of they they
look to improve but women we just blame
the men forever so her let me let me get
this straight okay like do you guys hear
these stories do you do you do you hear
these stories let me let me get this
straight her boyfriend watched red pill
content started talking about some stuff
she didn't
like and didn't want to deal with her
poor emotional
control I just want to point out a
couple red flags watching this video why
is she calling her boyfriend they like
that is the weirdest and the
glasses guys you already know the chicks
with the glasses half the time are these
crazy feminists it's like they put on
the feminist costume how can I make
myself as ugly as possible now I know
what you're going to say pearl there's
some women that actually can't see all
right I know I know I know but I mean
you know you know the type the thick
rimmed
like come on ladies come on um but but
seriously guys you know and she's saying
he's so controlling for saying you have
to obey me because that woman again and
I and I want to point out Britney rener
and I want to point out these are two
different girls but these are both two
women that have never heard what men
want and what role is supposed to be in
a
relationship this is over 50 years of
propaganda and telling women that were
just so amazing and really just
narcissism on steroids I think that's
the biggest problem in society I don't
think it's women's ability to cook
ability to clean I actually think the
biggest problem is
narcissism yes because whenever you say
to a chick no you are not amazing and
you are not the greatest thing since
sliced bread you're actually just a
normal chick and there's probably room
for improvement somewhere then I'm the
bad guy I'm so mean pearls just evil
evil evil and I'm just guys I'm just
tired I am just so tired of the simpery
and I'm tired of the
whining now this inspired a range of
tweets so if you guys don't follow me on
Twitter you should it's pearly things
and I've been going hard I really want
to hit half million TW tweets or a half
a million on Twitter this year um and so
I've I've just been tweeting up the
store there you know there's stages of
red pill and the first stage of red pill
is really realizing that women are not
up to par these are what the women are
grandmothers and mothers and mothers
were raised to do and did and we were
not taught any of that my generation was
just left a muck okay and then you start
to realize that this simping is just
crazy and what I realized is women are
really sensitive to aging whenever I
tweet anything about women looking
uglier yes at an older age all of the
women lose their minds now I want to I
want to tell you what started this
thought I had a tweet earlier this week
talking about how no at 35 you cannot
compete with 22y
olds and the reason I had that thought
was I looked at the most beautiful
35-year-old women that I know and I
thought to myself okay their their skin
still sags they still got light wrinkles
or they got a Botox forehead either or
you know whatever pick your poison um
they have fake whitened teeth like they
they've they've or maybe a fake BBL
whatever money they've put into staying
attractive I I don't care I'm not even
hating on it but my point is they spend
all of this money fake
boobs the gym
whatever only to not be able to compete
with a 22-year-old because I could go to
a college campus and find women hotter
and it wouldn't be hard it would be like
half of the campus um then what they'll
do is they is you see these copes you
see these like copes like they're like
ah not the younger women and they'll and
there's a couple copes that I really see
so cope number one well these women are
than
me really Rebecca you've had 15 years
and you think the 22 year-old's done
more
damage well yeah yeah yeah but it's the
new generation and I'm like well who
raised that
generation I okay so first it's them
trying to discredit their purity so
they'll be like oh well they're
sluder okay then they'll say well you
know I look better than them and I'm
like
really
really do
you and it's like okay guys there's
exceptions there's JLo okay JLo is
really hot but are you JLo really like
why as women do we have the sensitivity
to aging it's okay it doesn't have to be
the end of the world and I really just
had this series of tweets where I talked
about this by your 30s like you're not
supposed to be sexy anymore yes I said
it I said it
shoot the messenger I don't care I don't
care shoot the messenger because by your
30s you're supposed to have developed
wait for it guys
character yes yes yes and you know looks
and looking sexy and all that guys it
just looks kind of sad in your 30s it's
sad like this is delusion like it's
just it's embarrassing imagine being a
wife and a mother and all these women
will tweet tweet me their selfies like
please stop put it away I don't want to
see it and and they're they're these
only fans these old only fans models are
tweeting at me their nudes and this is
just exhausting and tiring so I see a
couple copes cope number one is well the
younger women are cope number
two is well the younger women are fatter
well I'm in better shape than these
young
women and the men will still pick them
over you sorry sorry and then three is
well I have a better my personality is
so much better is
it is it
really can we
just and what does that go back to
narcissism yes I am so special and
amazing and I need to argue with pearl
that I am hotter than the 22y olds 25y
olds I just need to prove Pearl wrong
and then what do they do they call Pearl
ugly oh well Pearl you look
old and
and and I would say the 22y olds are
hotter you know calling me ugly doesn't
make you any hotter Diane and this is
the thing these old women it's just like
and and I think to myself wow these are
wives and
mothers that raised us these are the
wives and mothers that will raise the
next generation of children dear God I
this is why I think that some women
should not have children
because can you imagine having that
level of
narcissism can you imagine being so
narcissistic that you can you cannot
read a tweet about younger women being
hotter without taking it personally and
crying to me about it wow Pearl you are
just the meanest where you know I just
think it's better that we live in
reality and understand that we age and
as we age we will be valued for
different things um really in the world
unfortunately the number one agency that
we have is beauty you will make the most
money off of beauty and you will get the
highest Suitor off of beauty character
does not compete with beauty I don't say
this with a happy heart I I don't I
don't say this because I'm happy about
it but it's just reality men are looks
first looks is where it starts and the
22 year olds are going to have you beat
sorry sorry like please stop whining to
me about this okay so then I get the
copes and I realize that men are they
are assistant they assist in this
delusion and how do they assist they say
hey and I realize that men do this so
they can get sex and I'll give you an
example I've noticed that broke men are
always the ones that'll say oh well I
like them
thick do do
you do you I mean there's a difference
between thick and
obese all right there there's a
difference there there's a all right I I
understand there might be a little curvy
a little less curvy but let's be honest
let's just I you don't see any Rich
handsome
men with anything but women with small
wastes oh shoot the messenger ah Pearl's
so mean Pearl's the
mean and the reason Reon that I say this
is not because this is the next coat
Pearl is just so miserable and she's
just
so I just cry myself to sleep every
night really and I do this because I'm
just really sick of seeing pandering I
am sick of seeing the media the
marketing I am sicking I am I am sick of
seeing the right and the left Pander so
I had another tweet and this one really
hit people where it hurts and instead of
asking is it true what do the women do
they attack your girl pearl the big
meanie so I tweeted I said no your
husband doesn't have husband goggles he
notices you aging simping is an epidemic
now what did I mean by this now number
one is this true or is it
false wait for it crickets does do
husbands notice that women
age yeah and I noticed I had I'll tell
you what made me think of this
phenomenon I noticed that when men
showed pictures of their wives to me it
was always a picture from like 10 years
ago they notice you know and this
doesn't mean this does not mean that men
will leave you high and dry that they
cannot love you for different things
this does not not mean you are worthless
if you age but what it does mean is
husband goggles are not real it's just a
thing that men say to make women feel
better about getting old now and what do
I what do I mean by simping simping is
telling women what we want to hear so we
can live in delusion for a
lifetime um and another thing that made
me think of this
was I've heard of cases of um let's just
say guys as they get into their 60s or
70s you know having erectile dysfunction
right and really they're just not
attracted to their wives like they used
to be because they're getting older
right it's one thing to have a 30s
something year old wife but this idea
that if you marry your husband at 25
that he is not going to notice that you
aged by 65 is just delusion it's just
not true this isn't to hate on marriage
this isn't me being mean but this is
just me saying it would be good for us
to live in reality looks aren't
everything and the second half of your
life as women character is the most
important thing because nobody is that
hot over 35 all right if you want to
extend it and make it 40 so be it but
the point of the matter is there is a
cut off for looks as women I see the
most beautiful women on the planet from
20 30 40 years ago that look crazy now
an example of this is Madonna she was a
beautiful world renowned pop star
Britney Spears is another one now are
they really hot sexy no they keep taking
off their clothes and it is sad and
depressing and I am depressed that the
level of wives and mothers on the market
right now are really just selling us
these dreams so now mind you I don't
know much about this chick so when I use
these people as examples I don't know
anything about their lives they very
well could be amazing awesome people
don't know but what I point out is I
typically can tell a lot by a chick by
how she reacts to being told she is not
the hottest thing since sliced bread I
think this chick was one of them when I
tweeted that at 25 you are hotter than
35 and she just really needed to show me
her selfies wow that is exactly what I
needed a post wall women's selfies thank
you now she says Pearl is upset that
she's aging out of the system she
insists leads to happiness and because
she is miserable and alone so there we
go Attack
One you she didn't say you're wrong she
said you are miserable and
alone oh yes I just
cry every night died in my misery she
wants happily married couples to be
miserable
too oh how did you know
Sarah how did you know all right it's
not simping it's called being in love
she has clearly never experienced and is
likely to ever experience with that
insufferable attitude she is a cancer so
I have I'm just going to take my notes
of this super happy wife and mother I
think you know seems very happy um
sorry and so she said you are
upset you are I mean she says aging out
so just you know old and
ugly whatever
um you want us to be
miserable um
you will never you'll be alone forever
and you're a cancer
where is the she is
wrong where where is it am I
wrong why like I just cannot take this
simpery I cannot take this outrage when
they never answer the question am I
wrong now it's you know Pearl is just
this ugly chick never attacking what I
said or the argument which really if you
listen to I had about like 50 tweets on
this I'm just a tweeter it's so easy
it's like you can just pull one I had
like 50 tweets on this where I explained
that you're not supposed to be hot in
your 30s because it is about
character yes it is very sad when these
wives and mothers are clutching on to
their youth that they no longer have and
and trying to be the these hot young
chicks that they're just not anymore
you're supposed to evolve and just
become you know the grandma that's like
baking cookies and stuff they used to
know this you know and there's a reason
I didn't come up with these terms guys a
lot of the stuff like leftover women old
made like this wasn't me these have been
common terms in all of
history Pearl isn't what guys want she's
tall not feminine masculine can logical
argumentative
controlling um for her to find love she
needs a robot dude like
her so it's just back to the personal
attacks personal attacks personal
attacks you know I I thought this was a
Marketplace of ideas and what you'll see
from the conservative Christians a lot
is they attack me personally why why is
what I am saying Incorrect and that's
what we have to default to what is truth
what is real not oh boohoo Pearl pointed
out that you get old do you know how
many messages I get from happily married
wives and it warms my heart because
women that are happily married are not
concerned about what the internet thinks
what Pearl thinks and they are certainly
only concerned about what their husband
thinks and they know that they age they
know that they get older but they are
focused on character and those wives
typically know their husbands like the
back of their hand they know it doesn't
matter if a younger chick is hotter
because I know my husband so well they
could never compete they have spent
their lives becoming amazing phenomenal
wives and they do exist and they are out
there and most of them I hate to break
it to you agree with me yes yes and it's
unfortunate because the women that go on
social media talking about how amazing
of a wife they are typically aren't the
ideal like typ and guys there's
exceptions I could point to you
exceptions but the issue is and why
aren't they the ideal because what is
the number what is one of the best
traits of a wife
humility humility wait for it humility
you are not the best thing since sliced
bread and they know I pointed out on my
show yesterday that
when that when the feminist answered the
question about
traditionalism she was very arrogant
where the housewife answers the question
about
traditionalism and she says I always try
to put my husband's needs first and the
way you answer questions is really I
don't know you can just there's just
something you can see about women that
just have humility they know they're not
perfect they know they're not amazing
but they do the best that they can and
they're not busy tweeting their selfies
at me all right like this is just C like
please and and I wanted to point out one
thing just to make myself clear no no
this is not me attacking marriage no
this is not me saying that your husband
will not love you for different things
my whole point is that I think that we
should live in reality with the fact
that we age and stop crying about the
fact that we age and make up all these
words to make us feel better about aging
now you get uglier the older you get and
that's okay because you can have better
character for your family and loved
ones wow so speaking of um younger women
dating older men I've noticed this
phenomenon where if a man dates a woman
significantly younger than him they
throw insults at him like he is
a a creep and no please women please do
not come at me and say oh Pearl you're
you're promoting underage women no no no
no not saying that nope nope nope please
do not put that because that's what you
guys always do try to make it me say
something I didn't say so Emanuel Maron
is 45 years old his wife is 70 years old
25 years his senior they have zero
children together how and when did they
meet you ask when he was a 15-year-old
school boy and she was a married
40-year-old teacher
this is apparently fine even celebrated
by feminists wokes and some
conservatives but a 51-year-old Dane
Cook marrying a 24-year-old Kelsey
Taylor is somehow grooming make it make
sense why are younger men praised for
marrying post metapa women but older men
are shamed for marrying young fertile
women because feminism and depopulation
that's why Kelsey Taylor is beautiful I
am happy for them and you should be too
and yes they plan to have children
children together stop shaming older men
for marrying young fertile women thanks
for coming to my TED Talk I
agree I agree you know this just doesn't
like look natural the woman's supposed
to be like the hottie you know what I
mean like she's supposed to and this is
one thing we don't talk about you know
it's considered grooming When A Man
dates a younger woman and may I'm not
even saying it's not but when a woman
does it nobody bats an eye you don't see
anyone outraged but when a woman dates
an older
man then everybody's upset I've even
heard tradcon shame guys for getting the
youngest hottest option they can get why
why like why is this a bad thing
feminists wanted equality so be equal be
equal stop whining and crying when men
date younger if you're not going to
whine and cry when women date younger I
just say over the age of8 18 people can
do what they want so you know today um I
have a story from Reddit my producers
give me these um all right so I found
out my father isn't my real father I
thought my college Journey was Secure
just like my older siblings who had
their expenses covered by our dad
however I recently learned that my dad
isn't my biological father due to my
mom's Affair shockingly my dad has
decided to stop supporting my college
education putting the responsibility on
my mom to have told me this earlier I
feel abandoned and unprepared for my
future I've never had a job and don't
know how to secure loans for college my
relationship with my parents is strained
and I'm grappling with feelings of
rejection and confusion about my
identity I'm looking for advice on how
to navigate this tough situation that
has left me feeling lost and uncertain
about my place in the family um this is
a classic example of the children
suffering for the sins of the mother and
guys once you realize that everything in
all of the problems in society really do
come come from the sins of the mother
simps enabling the mother really I mean
this is the natural order of the world
is God men women children and when you
disrupt that order and you have women
acting out of pocket and men not
checking them uh that's when evil
happens and I really think that women
like this should face fraud charges if a
man steals money and time from people he
goes to jail but for women for whatever
reason they can steal a man's money
resources and even worse emotional you
know I mean I can't even imagine raising
someone thinking that's my own um just
to find out another man was the father
that's that's devastating to a guy and
women like that should face jail time so
what would my um advice be to someone
like this I I think that's a terrible
situation and I really if I was him I
would actually try to get in touch with
the dad um I've had experience on
adoption on both sides and I do think
there is something about reconnecting
with like your family from birth it kind
of helps you put some pieces together um
because and this is kind of a touchy
topic but you know in my experience
blood is thicker than water and there's
always going to be something that you
get from your someone that's blood um
over water this is just I know some
people have terrible relationships with
their family so they just will be like
Pearl you're just chatting but I
don't know if I was him I would I would
actually go try to have a conversation
with the dad but let me know what you
guys think in the comments um subscribe
to the channel also get yourself a women
should and vote t-shirt guys this would
never happen this Reddit story wouldn't
happen if women voted or if women didn't
have the right to vote like the video on
your way out and I'll talk to you next
time